all right a new challenger has entered
the pennsylvania senate race and it is
television dr mehmet oz known for being
a purveyor of quack cures and
pseudoscience
can't even really call them treatments
really shouldn't even call them cures uh
we're going to get to that um television
doctor mehmet oz is running for senate
in pennsylvania as a republican and he's
a complete disgrace to the medical field
and if he were senator it would be yet
another complete disgrace to this
country but trump won
so dr oz could certainly win there is a
good candidate in that race and it's a
really important race
the good candidate is john fetterman a
lieutenant governor of pennsylvania
and now we have a really bad candidate
dr oz has promoted all sorts of quack
cures for years he's the opposite of
what we need in power and here is his
big announcement that he is running
my parents came to america to find a
better life and they did i attended
great universities raised a family and
became a successful surgeon i invented a
heart valve that saves thousands of
lives
then i started a tv show to advocate for
you taking control of your health
and took on the medical establishment to
argue against costly drugs and
skyrocketing medical bills
but covid has shown us that our system
is broken we lost too many lives too
many jobs and too many opportunities
because washington got it wrong they
took away our freedom without making us
safer and tried to kill our spirit and
our dignity
as a heart surgeon i know how precious
life is
pennsylvania needs a conservative who
will put america first one who can
reignite our divine spark bravely fight
for freedom and tell it
like it is that's why i'm running for
senate i'm dr oz and i approve this
message
this is a major senate race in 2022 in
pennsylvania
this senate race could decide who
controls the senate in the next term
democrats or republicans it's going to
be an open seat the incumbent republican
senator pat toomey has said he's not
running for re-election joe biden won
pennsylvania in 2020 but pennsylvania is
really a state that particularly on
senate can can go either way even on
presidential it's not uh typically a big
win for one side or the other it's a
fight and dr oz is exactly the type of
celebrity that republicans would love to
vote for and he's truly horrible uh he
has done a lot of horrible things on his
show just to some examples he held a
debate about gay reparative therapy as
if there's a legitimate conversation
about it this is like when a network
says we're going to debate climate
change
and they bring on someone who
understands and states the facts
and someone else who just presents a
completely wacky conspiracy view and
presents them as if they are even dr oz
did the same thing with gay reparative
therapy dr oz promoted green coffee bean
extract for weight loss
there are no weight loss benefits to
green coffee bean extract it's one of
these
purported things that has since been
admitted to being bogus he promoted the
use of hydroxychloroquine to treat covid
on multiple fox news broadcasts and of
course as many of you know
um i listed hydroxychloroquine back at
that time along with seven or eight
other things that were being looked at
as does this work the fda revoked an eua
for hydroxychloroquine saying there was
no reason to believe that it was
effective against covid19
uh he has been uh pushing remember he's
an actual this is not like you know uh
when oh doctor but it's not a medical
doctor so you've got a this is a medical
doctor and he still pushes nonsense uh
dr oz supportive of homeopathy which is
just completely debunked i know some
people in the audience get mad at me
guys it's totally debunked there's often
no active ingredients in it in
measurable quantities
it has been uh determined that
homeopathy cannot treat or cure any
condition of any kind period it's just
it's nothing okay i'm sorry guys it's
just nothing
dr oz promoted energy therapies of
different kinds
he's expressed support for faith healing
he is kowtowed to psychic communication
and much more
dr oz has repeatedly claimed that
raspberry
oh man he has claimed that raspberry
ketones are the number one miracle in a
bottle to burn your fat
he has said astrological signs may
reveal a great deal about your health
and saying that for centuries we've used
astrological signs to examine our
personalities and how we interact
but there may be much to be revealed
about our health as well that's not true
that's that's a lie
um dr oz said that most countries
require genetically modified foods to be
specially labeled sort of implying that
it's because gmos are unsafe now the
reality is that most countries do not
require such labels
gmo foods have been studied and have
found to be safe now the issue of
pesticides is often intermingled with
gmo pesticides are a different story but
gmos have been studied and there's no
evidence that they are unsafe for human
consumption there's something called
umkolobo i don't even know if i'm
pronouncing that correctly it's a root
extract and he says that it's been
incredibly effective at relieving cold
symptoms even though that's not true
there are not reliable studies on that
and then
remember when he said that you know what
if we open schools
we might have two to three percent
mortality but that would be a good trade
what remember this from april of 2020 on
the sean hannity program dr oz help us
well first we need our mojo back let's
start with things that are really
critical to the nation where we think we
might build open without getting into a
lot of trouble i tell you schools are a
very appetizing opportunity uh i just
saw a nice piece in the lancer arguing
that the opening of schools may only
cost us two to three percent in terms of
total mortality and you know that's any
life is a life loss but to get every
child back into a school where they're
safely being educated being fed
and making the most out of their lives
with the theoretical risk in the
backside it might be a trade-off some
folks would consider wow and i mean
that's just completely bonkers first of
all once schools opened we saw that it
was insane spread and once months later
obviously schools opened and it was just
like immediately this entire class has
has to quarantine
florida educators dying all over i mean
just crazy two to three percent of
mortality is a trade-off that we might
make so you know there was a point where
we would never imagine that a guy like
this would have a shot
except donald trump won
and dr oz could clearly win dr oz could
be the person who takes the senate from
democrats in 2022. now fortunately we
have a great option and that's john
fetterman running in pennsylvania this
isn't an endorsement
but i like fetterman we have good
options is the point pat toomey's
retiring republican senators retiring
and it's not like it's dr oz or nobody
we have at minimum john fetterman i know
there are other candidates running on
both the democratic and republican sides
there will be primaries to choose who
ultimately makes it to the general
election in uh november now only 11
months away guys it's
it's the midterms we're in the midterms
already
um and it would be an absolute disaster
if dr oz were to win
let's next look at the welcome with open
arms that dr oz received on fox news
over the last 24 to 48 hours
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies i've been drinking
four sigmatic coffee a lot lately it
actually doesn't taste anything like
mushrooms it just tastes like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling or a midday crash and they have
over 20 000 five-star reviews and best
of all if you don't love it you'll get
100
of your money back because they stand
behind their product you've got nothing
to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off and free shipping
when you go to four sigmatic dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video